eins zu eins wie vor wie teilnehmer sie
an mich weg sehr begrüßen
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es endlich
mal so ich war letztens sushi essen
allerdings crispy sushi und dann habe
ich auf installierung befragt möchte
immer ein rezept dazu um meine
nachrichten doch super dies komplett
geplatzt und ich hab gedacht ich mach
das jetzt direkt ich bin jetzt nicht so
der größte ski fans vielleicht
entwickelt sich das ja auch noch in den
nächsten jahren aber was ist liebe ist
christi sushi das ist so die anfänger
version wenn man nicht so der fan ist
aber dadurch dass es friert ist und mit
dem panel und pankow es so lecker auf
jeden fall starte ich jetzt mit dem
sushi reis ich erkläre ich heute alles
schritt für schritt das wird anfänger
geeignet sein und ich schreibe euch die
ganz genauen mengenangaben hier unten in
die infobox da könnte einfach aufklappen
und dann steht da alles screenshot
einkaufen gehen und nachmachen so film
sushi reis brauchen wir rundkornreis es
ist aber auch als sushi reis deklariert
und das muss man auswaschen das ist ganz
wichtig dass die stärkere ausgewaschen
mir dass er nicht so pampig wird das
macht ihr so lange bis unten das wasser
relativ klar wieder rauskommt ist nicht
glasklar rauskommen aber ihr merkt einen
unterschied das dauert auch so ungefähr
zwei bis drei minuten unter lauwarmes
kaltem wasser und dann machen wir weiter
hier am herd da habe ich jetzt schon
wasser in einem topf ihr müsst das am
besten mit gläsern ab ich habe zum
beispiel so man sagt immer so eine tasse
sushi reis und dann kommt einer und halb
tassen wasser mit dazu ich mache es
immer so ich habe jetzt hier zum
beispiel für das rezept 2000 sushi reist
und dann mache ich nicht ganz 3000
wasser sondern so ein tag weniger damit
einfach nicht so pampig wird und das
gebe ich jetzt die auch noch nicht rein
so lag es einmal aufkochen gibt dann den
sushi reis daran dass darf in so ein bis
zwei minuten köcheln und dann geht ihr
runter auf die mittlere hitze und lasst
es so lange weiter bis man das wasser
quasi nicht mehr sieht und ab dem
zeitpunkt einfach nur noch garen lassen
ich mache da stufe 2 von 9
[Musik]
der reißt gab jetzt vor sich hin dass
braucht so 10 bis 15 minuten wichtig ist
nur dass er den deckel drauf gibt
zwischendurch dürfte gerne immer mal
wieder reinschauen und verrühren das ist
gar kein problem
ich mache jetzt weiter mit der reis
würze dafür brauchen wir reis essig der
schmeckt viel milder als normal oder
andere es sich den wir so kennen also
nicht einfach gegen irgendein es sich
austauschen wenn ihr den gerade nicht da
habt dann habe ich aber auch nur gehört
kann balsamico bianco ganz gut schmeckt
aber ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert
daher verlasst euch nicht drauf nimmt
gerne den reis es sich für dieses rezept
und gebt da dann ein bisschen zucker und
salz mit dazu einfach nur verrühren und
dann geben wir das gleich mit zum warmen
sushi reis wenn er fertig gegart ist es
gibt noch eine andere möglichkeit man
könnte das einmal kurz erwärmen dann
lösen sich die zuckerkristalle auf aber
dadurch dass du das sowieso in den
warmen sehr warm reis geben lösen sich
die zuckerkristalle auch darauf aber das
zeige ich euch gleich noch
[Musik]
so den sushi reis haben wir jetzt
gewürzt wichtig ist dass sie den einfach
zugedeckt noch mal zur seite stellt ein
bisschen abkühlen dass ein bisschen
beziehen last und ich bereite der
zwischenzeit die füllung vor ich mache
heute eine füllung mit gemüse was ich
gerade so dahab zum beispiel möhren rote
paprika und habe ich noch avantgarde und
engagiere heißen jetzt nochmal surimi
sticks ich würde sony kaufen ich kaufe
ich es nur für sushi und nicht jubelt
die dem haben sie so ein bisschen unter
ich hab dir weiß gar nicht dass das was
dem fisch zu tun hat lasst uns jetzt
einfach so stehen ich studiert alles
schön feinen so streifen bereite alles
vor und dann können wir auch schon
anfangen alles einzuräumen
[Musik]
so jetzt wird erfüllt wir nehmen uns
einmal das neue blatt mit der rauen
seite nach oben
und da kommen jetzt zuallererst reis
drauf da könnt ihr euch zu hilfe
zwischendurch auch mal die hände mit
kaltem wasser bevor ich damit ist
einfach besser und einfacher verteilen
könnt dieser petition und runter auch
auf der arbeitsfläche zu hilfe eine
frischhaltefolie einfach damit ich
später leichter umdrehen kann und nicht
gefahr laufen dass es irgendwie anpackt
und wir machen deshalb die raue seite
jetzt schon nach oben weil das ja gleich
umgedreht wird das heißt ein bisschen
vorstellen diese seite mit dem reiss
hier die ist gleich außen und da kommt
gleich noch mal so eine schöne parade
drumherum das heißt gleich wenn wir das
umgedreht haben dann nehme ich mir
einfach diese bambus rolle zu hilfe
werden wir quasi unsere füllungen auf
die glatte seite gehen ich noch ein
bisschen für day4 und runter das ist
aber geschmackssache und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr da auch noch so ein
bisschen wahrsagen mit dem finger drauf
streichen ich mag es nicht so scharf
deswegen dass ich das weg und dann
wollen wir das einfach nur noch auf
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die sozis komplett
geräumt und man kann auch hier ganz gut
sehen ich habe übrigens vier stück raus
bekommen die eine liegt noch hier vorne
man kann ganz gut sehen dass dir super
dick ist dadurch einfach mehr erfüllung
gemacht da könnt ihr den frischkäse
einfach ein bisschen weiter rein
streichen und einfach ein bisschen mehr
gemüse nehmen das ist so hamm saß
lieblingsvariante der makel so richtig
groß und ich mag es in kleiner ist man
ist es somit 2 hubs in einem und so mag
ich das am nächsten und jetzt brauchen
wir quasi den pannier teig dafür habe
ich hier einmal temporär teig mischung
die findet dem asiatischen supermarkt
nach packungsanleitung einfach mit
wasser vermischen und das mache ich
jetzt eben
also ihr könnt es auf jeden fall darauf
achten dass diese tempura teig mischung
nicht zu flüssig ist für unseren zweck
ich habe es einfach packungsanleitung
gemacht und muss sagen es ist mir ein
bisschen zu dass ich schreibe euch mal
unten infobox wie ich das vermischt habe
sollte auf jeden fall ein bisschen
fester sein räumt ihr einfach die sushi
rolle in den temporär teig und dann und
jetzt kommt das wichtigste er braucht
pankow paniermehl das ist dieses
asiatische paniermehl und das ist
einfach so ein bisschen gröber dann
rollt ihr das nochmal hier durch das
pankower nämlich und dann wird es
kritisch
[Musik]
zum frittierfett noch ein tipp von mir
ich hab nämlich auch kein thermometer
oder so was ich mache das man mit einem
schaschlikspieß ich halt den reihen wenn
die blasen sehr langsam aufsteigen dann
ist es noch zu kalt wenn sie zu schnell
aufsteigen dann ist es zu heiß und das
mittelmaß ist dann quasi genau die
richtige temperatur um solche dinge zu
frittiert mit sind sie perfekt goldbraun
die vierte rolle braucht er noch ein
bisschen also achtet einfach gern darauf
dass die rolle komplett gold frauen ist
am anfang kann es minute länger dauern
die zweite vogel kann dann ein bisschen
schneller gehen das ist ganz normal weil
das fällt er dann schon auf temperatur
ist und als nächstes würde ich mal sagen
schneiden wir das einfach auf mit einem
scharfen messer und dann könnt ihr das
revier major sauce mit japanischer mio
ihr könnt einfach so genießen sojasauce
darf nicht fehlen oder oder oder da
gibt's 1000 möglichkeiten und wir sehen
uns dann gleich zum test wieder
[Musik]
wir holen uns jetzt zwei gabel wir
können nicht steht warum stäbchen kann
sich auch bestimmte figur argument aber
weil wir jetzt groß geredet das muss
jetzt einmal mit stäbchen soll ich nur
zeigen dass
wir gerne so schnell
es ist elegant ist tot für streben ein
alter was ist da drin das ist ne das ist
der gemüse
spreche ich dass ich hoffe dass ich
irgendwas kitschiges sieht das doch hier
wieder bestellen
ich gucke dazu das was wenn wir
bestellen ist das genau das gleiche
kostet das rote da was ist dann das ja
nur therapie
für dich
das mache ich mach das jetzt so
wie diese tomkat so sie letztens
entdeckt zu haben
habe ich mir mit japanischer meinung
nach darauf gegeben das ist letztlich
gute hand
eins zu eins wie vor vier tagen war sie
wirklich eins zu eins ist kein
unterschied nicht mehr weiter wissen
es besser ich finde richtig lecker
folgen sprich von der männer recht ich
denke also schönster kann sie hatten
jetzt mal was
ehrlich die süße ist das geile ist halt
wirklich außen so die sektoren ist
dieses pankow nicht dieses normale
fannie mae mir ist übertrieben kranjec
und dann beißt du dich solche sushi reis
auch die schwester verlor also jetzt bei
der jetzt weil es schmeckt vielen frisch
haben weil er ist meist ein bisschen ab
riga ich finde es auch richtig lecker
ich bin das mit dem tempo rateike genial
wird dieser geschmack man schmeckt ich
weiß es ich raus der reis ist lecker
gewürzt
dass hier das kubanische was ist das
erklärt entdeckt dass orange habe beim
alten auch immer drin aber du hast es
bis jetzt noch nie gemerkt haben sie
etwas die ganze zeit was mit gegessen
und siehst du das heißt pro star aus
polen du magst das nämlich schlägt
ja also ich war ja dass ich werde es auf
jeden fall öfter machen ich wünsche euch
ganz geschlossen nach machen welche
social rezept soll ich als nächstes
machen schreibt man das gerne meine
kommentare weil das nach die auch
abgestimmt er so viele nach und nach zu
muss man ja wohl
[Musik]